cuando las personas hablan o se refieren
a inflación están hablando de inflación
en los precios es el incremento general
en el nivel de los precios para bienes y
servicios yo supongo que tú has
escuchado o tienes una noción de todo
esto en una economía normal las cosas
tienden o parece ser que se vuelven un
poco más caras cada año por ejemplo la
educación la educación es algo que
realmente si sube cada año de precio
bueno una interesante pregunta está
siguiente cómo se mide la inflación cómo
se mide la inflación lo que hacen las
oficinas estadísticas del trabajo es
crear el ipc índice de precios al
consumidor y como lo hacen es definir
una canasta de bienes y servicios van y
observan al consumidor urbano promedio y
dicen bueno a ver ellos que necesitan en
su vida diaria
por ejemplo vivienda ellos necesitan
vivienda también por ejemplo gasolina
energía tú sabes hay que viajar al
trabajo a la tienda si está retirada la
tienda también por ejemplo servicios
servicios y claro
y transportación también se requiere
ellos tratan de complementar esta
canasta de todos los bienes y servicios
que un consumidor urbano promedio podría
necesitar y averiguan cuánto sería el
costo de esa canasta en el año 1 año 1 y
digamos que en el año 1 esa canasta
tiene un costo de 100 pesos
supongamos esto yo estoy obviamente
exagerando en el número pero bueno es
para simplificar las cosas tú sabes me
dirán todo esto basado en el porcentaje
que ellos creen que se gastó en esa
canasta luego observarán los datos en la
misma canasta pero cada año después la
canasta con lo mismo vivienda gasolina
servicios transportación esto sería en
el año 2 año 2 y digamos que esa misma
canasta cuesta ahora 102 pesos 102 pesos
y después ellos dirán que el nivel
general del precio en servicio subió por
2 pesos o más importante cruzando el
porcentaje subió por 2 por ciento así
que basado en esa medida basado en la
canasta de bienes los precios subieron
por 2 por ciento más 2 por ciento
escucharás en los noticieros a los
reporteros decir que la tasa de
inflación subió por 2%
ahora quiero clarificar algo a veces se
refieren la inflación por la oferta del
dinero más dinero está siendo impreso y
frecuentemente el incremento en la
oferta del dinero es un factor que
conduce a la inflación en los precios
comúnmente cuando las personas hablan de
inflación se refieren a inflación en los
precios al incremento en los precios no
están directamente refiriéndose al
incremento en la oferta de dinero y tal
vez pienses que este asunto es pan
comido pero no lo es no no porque
observa esto por ejemplo las cosas de
tecnología un atv por ejemplo cual toman
en cuenta la que se devalúa cada año
porque ahora ya hay una mejora y una
mejor y más grande o también en las
computadoras a cual toman en cuenta
porque las computadoras
significativamente se devalúan cada año
a una computadora del año pasado es
ahora mucho más barata cada vez hay más
tecnología mejores computadoras hay
mucho en qué pensar aquí muchas formas
en cómo medir esto y también hay mucha
controversia en los cambios de los
costos de algunas cosas tan simultáneos
pero es una idea general y un buen
intento para averiguar un promedio de
cuanto más caro o que tanto poder
adquisitivo estamos perdiendo de un año
al siguiente